[Music]
[Applause]
you
I guess we're in Vancouver Wow all right
that is daunting so I hope you'll
indulge me here for a second
Jordan and Sam have given me the honor
of moderating this debate or discussion
depending on how you view it and I think
that actually creates a certain kind of
responsibility and I want to talk to you
about my responsibilities and how I see
it
and my respite sense of how you all have
responsibilities in this as well
I suspect that what's gonna happen
tonight is actually historical which
doesn't necessarily make it good there's
lots of bad history it could be good
though and that's what I'm hoping will
happen so the reason I say I think it's
historical is that we are existing in a
moment where all of the systems that
have helped us make sense are breaking
down the university systems are breaking
down journalism is breaking down and at
that same moment we have a network of
people who are trying to make sense in
an alternative way and I have to say I
think beating the odds for the moment so
here's the problem that network is not
entirely in agreement with itself about
some significant issues and Sam and
Jordan have some differences that have
proved very difficult
so what could happen tonight is we could
have some sort of a failure where things
get even more muddled we could tread
water where nothing gets clear maybe it
would be entertaining maybe it wouldn't
but best-case scenario is that we figure
out how to make sense of things that
have gotten in our way before and if
that happens then you all will leave
here and as you talk in your various
networks you will have something to say
about in what way we upgraded our
software so that we could talk more
deeply about difficult issues so to that
end we would ask the King not film
tonight's discussion and broadcast it
online
it's not that we want to hide this in
fact we encourage you to discuss it but
we would like to have all of us feel
maximally free to speak here to try out
positions that we haven't tried out
before in the hopes that we can get
somewhere new all right so
I think with that we will just put Sam
and Jordan to it and see if we can head
towards some of the discussions that
have proved difficult in the past I
think I'll just start by saying that
when we first had the idea to do this
now some months ago I'm getting a little
reverb here so if you can dial down
there's little feedback when Jordan and
I first decided to do an event together
it was after we did those somewhat
ill-fated podcasts and I joked that we
would probably need a safe word for this
event so that safe word as will come as
no surprise is lobster
so you'll know things are dire when one
of us says that but you know I just want
to express my motive for for helping to
stage these events and because I you
know I I reached out to Jordan and it
really was born of seeing him in
conversation with people other than
myself I saw him do a podcast with Joe
Rogan I saw him speak to Dave Rubin as
I'm speak with Brett on on Rogen's
podcast and I had so much admiration for
him in those conversations it's 90
percent of what he said in those
conversations struck me as really wise
and useful and well-intentioned and 10
percent didn't and but I noticed that it
was close
clear to me that that you've seen these
successful conversations with other
people who I respect I began to wonder
that you know I might be the problem and
I think I I think I am the problem I
think
well before you applaud maybe I didn't
mean that quite the way you took it I
think it's I think it's a good sort of
problem for Jordan to have because it's
what happens on those 10% moments and
and what doesn't happen that I think
made our conversation so hard and and I
think we there is stuff to clarify
between us so I look forward to doing
that and thank you Jordan for agreeing
to do this it's an honor to share the
stage with you and needless to say
having Brett as a moderator as a almost
obscene underestimation of the role he
should be playing on any stage because
he as you know he's been on my podcast
and that was one of the best
conversations I've ever had so thank you
for doing this
[Music]
all right so I'm gonna jump right into
it I think here so look this is I put up
a poll a couple of days ago to find out
what people broadly speaking might want
us to discuss and I've been taking a
look at that and I took a lot of notes
which is why I have my computer here by
the way on my phone it's not to check my
email well the debates going on the
discussion I thought what I might do is
just lay out some places that I think
Sam and I agree and because there's lots
of places we agree and so and then I
want to figure out where we disagree
which I've been trying to sort out and
then I want to see if we can hash it out
a little bit and and move forward on
that a bit so I'm going to lay out see
one of the things that Carl Rogers said
this psychic psychologist was that one
good way to have a discussion with
someone is to tell them what you think
they think until they think that what
you said reflects what they said but
look this is a really useful thing to
know if you're ever having a discussion
with an intimate partner for example is
that you have to put their argument back
to them in terms they agree with it's
very difficult so I'm going to try to do
that and so so the first thing is I
think I think that partly what's driving
you if this is accurate is that you want
to ground a structure of ethics in
something solid and and and there's two
there's two things you want to avoid two
catastrophes let's say one is the
catastrophe that you identified with
religious fundamentalism and the other
is the catastrophe that's associated
with moral relativism that is that
reasonable yeah that's good
okay good good okay well
okay so it's crucially it's crucially
important that we get this right now so
be and that's something that I think we
really agree on because I've
conceptualized that slightly different
than you and that might be relevant but
I think of that as a pathology of order
and a pathology of chaos so the
terminology is slightly different but I
think we're working on the same axis so
so so that's the first thing and then in
order to do that it seems to me that's
your first priority then maybe your
second priority is something like you
know you see undo suffering in the world
plenty of it and you would think that
things would be better if that wasn't
the case and that this morality whatever
it's going to be is at least going to
part ground itself in part on the
presupposition that the less undo
suffering in the world the better so is
that also reasonable yeah I would just
add to that the the positive side of the
continuum as well so as you know the
phrase I use though the word I use for
this is well-being yeah
and I know from having I don't think we
spoke about this on my podcast but from
having seen you in other interviews I I
think you think that phrase doesn't
capture everything one could reasonably
want but I think it does a mattress I've
you know it's an elastic suitcase term
for a reason and it's it's actually in
reading your book I realize there's a
point of contact here because you use
the word beam capital B beam with as
though it were imbued with significant
gravitas and so for me and I agree with
you that's an appropriate use of being
and for me well-being is simply just the
positive side of being you know there's
the negative side the suffering we want
to mitigate but I think I think however
good consciousness can be in this
universe that the well-being for me
subsumes all of those possibilities okay
well so what so I focused on the
suffering element I think as I've done
in my own work because I actually think
it's easier to zero in on in some sense
like I think it's easier for people and
I think you lay out the argument in the
moral landscape kind of like this I
think
it's easier perhaps to gain initial
agreement between people on what might
constitute a generalized ethic to
concentrate on what we don't want yeah
I'm not saying that what we do want is
unimportant but it seems to me to be
harder to get a grip on we don't want
our swift's we don't want the Gulag
Archipelago
so and and there are those and I would
add to just closing the door to moral
relativism here those who do want
outwits are wrong to want auschwitz
obviously it's only happened because
some people did want now it's not the
victims side but the perpetrator side
and so crucially for me is the claim
that I'm a realist I'm a moral realist
and what realism means is that it's
there that there are right and wrong
answers to questions of this kind and
and and you can not know what you're
missing in fact we almost certainly
don't know what we're missing on
questions of human value and that and
our job is to discover just how good
life can be and just what variables are
making it needlessly horrible and to to
mitigate all of that and live in a in a
better and better world ok ok ok so
that's a that's a that's a lot of points
of agreement so I also believe that
there is a catastrophe of of arbitrary
moral injunction and that there's a
catastrophe of moral relativism and that
that that has to be dealt with and that
there are genuine differences between
the proper way of behaving more lien and
the improper way of behaving morally and
I think that they are grounded in human
universals even though there's a wide
amount of variation so that that's a lot
of points of agreement right so we know
that there's two things we want to avoid
we conceptually speaking which is the
moral relativism and this kind of moral
absolutism that's grounded in an
arbitrary statement of facts that you
identify with religious fundamentalism I
would identify that with fundal it
fundamentalism more generally not not
with religious fundamentalism per se
because I see it also having happening
in secular states let's say like not too
many or so it doesn't seem to be
religious fundamentalism per se that's
crucial to your
argument no it's not it's a so that just
to close the loop on that the only
reason why I would focus on religion in
particular there is that religion is the
only language game where in
fundamentalism and of dogmatism where
dogmatism is not a pejorative concept
the dogma is a good word in specifically
within Catholicism and the notion that
you must believe things on faith that is
in the absence of compelling evidence it
would otherwise cause a rational person
to believe it that you know religious
context is considered a feature not a
bug
elsewhere we recognize it to be a bug
and that's that's why so it all right so
is it reasonable to assume that the
associate we've already established at
least in principle that there's an
association between the totalitarian
regimes let's say and dogmatism yeah and
the dogmatism that characterizes
religious belief what do you think
although at least in principle the the
secularists totalitarian states and the
religious fundamentalist totalitarian
states do differ in one important regard
which is that the religious types ground
their axioms in God and the secular
totalitarian types don't and so there's
got to be something about
totalitarianism per se that's
independent of that's associated with
religious belief in the matter that you
just described but that's not
particularly associated with the belief
in God there's something that makes them
that's a commonality between them and so
do you have any sense of what that might
be well I would I think one has to
acknowledge that there's something
uniquely pernicious at least potentially
about religious beliefs because they
they have the the otherworldly variable
the supernatural variable the you're
going to get everything you want after
you die so this life doesn't matter
issue that right that allows for kind of
misbehavior that is especially okay so
so it seems that so that the claim would
be that if you if you
put forward axiomatically your claim
that God exists then you can use that
claim to justify whatever arbitrary
atrocities your system might throw off
yeah but the only point I was making
there is that not all dogmas are created
equal but some dogmas are on their face
more dangerous and more devices right
but what I'm curious about specifically
is because it seems to me that the
dogmas of the USSR and the dogmas of
Nazi Germany were as pernicious as any
religious dogmas and and they may also
share important features with your
Nicias religious lives but it isn't
clear to me from your perspective what
those commonalities would be well so I
mean in some ways your recapitulated in
an argument I've made and this is an
argument that I would make against you
were you to claim as you've had you have
elsewhere that that atheism is
responsible for the greatest atrocities
of the 20th century the idea that
Stalinism and Nazism and fascism were
expressions of atheism simply doesn't
make any sense maybe in the case of
fascism and Nazism it doesn't make any
sense because the fascists and the Nazis
by and large were not even atheist emiru
Hitler wasn't it a theist and he was
talking about executing a divine plan
and he got lots of support from the
churches and the Vatican did nothing to
stop them and fascism as you know
coexisted quite happily with Catholicism
in Croatia and Portugal and Spain and
Italy so but even in the case of Stalin
what was so wrong with that
situation was where all the ways in
which it's so resembled a religion you
had a personality cult you had dogmatism
that held sway to a point where apostasy
and blasphemy were killing offenses you
know the people who didn't toe the line
were eradicated and you know so and
North Oh to take a more modern example
North Korea is a religious cult it just
doesn't happen to be a one that is
focused on the next life or you know
supernatural claims so what we magic the
folk okay so what would be the defining
characteristics of a religious total
pterri movement that would make it
different from a non-religious
totalitarian movement because there's
aspects that are similar yeah they may
be they're very similar but the problem
is dogmatism the overarching problem is
believing things strongly on bad
evidence and B and the reason why
dogmatism is so dangerous is that it is
it doesn't allow us to revise our bad
ideas in real time through conversation
it is it that dog must have to be
enforced by force or the threat of force
because the moment someone has a better
idea you have to shut it down in order
to preserve your dog okay okay so so the
commonality seems to be something like
claims of absolute truth at some level
that can't be that you're no longer
allowed to discuss yeah okay and so okay
so that's another point of agreement
then I would say because part of the
reason that I've been let's say a free
speech advocate although I don't think
that's the right way of thinking about
it is because I think of free discourse
like the discourse that we're engaged in
as the mechanism that corrects
totalitarian excess or dogmatic excess
and so I also think that systems of
governance that are laying themselves
out properly have to eval it have to
elevate the process by which dogmatic
errors are corrected over the dogmas
themselves which is why I think the
Americans are right say with regard to
their first amendment is the process of
free speech is the process by which
dogmatic errors are rectified and so it
has to be put at the pinnacle of the
hierarchy of values I think you and I
totally agree about the primacy of free
speech okay okay good okay so that's
another fine
[Applause]
okay so then we could think there's one
point that we should just lock in our
games here it sounds like what you're
saying is that the reason to fear
religious dogma is really on the dogma
side and not the religion side which at
least leaves open the possibility that
something could exist over on the
religion side that doesn't have that
characteristic right that often they
travel in tandem but the thing to fear
is not the religious belief it is the
dogmatic nature of the way it is yeah
well the other way to say that is the
only thing that's wrong with the
religion is the dogmatism if you get rid
of the door I've got no problem with the
buildings and the music and the and the
paintings and wait wait no that wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
that's not a trivial that's not a
trivial point and it's not just a joke
because the buildings and the music are
very important parts of the religious
process and so I know I know there's a
humorous element to that but it's not
like Sam is throwing out the baby with
the bathwater there and to go further
than that I've got no problem in fact
I'm deeply interested in the
phenomenology of spiritual experience so
so whatever experience someone like
Jesus had whoever he was historically or
any of the other major arts and
patriarchs of the world's religions
though that that phenomenology is is
subjectively real I mean that it's
diverse I'm not saying everyone's had
the same experience but there are
changes in consciousness that explain
both how religions have gotten founded
by their their founders and the
experiences people have had in the
presence of those people or by continued
following their methodologies that seem
to be confirming of the dogmas that got
that grew up around those traditions and
my issue is that whatever is true about
us spiritually whatever opportunity
being born to this universe actually
presents as a matter of consciousness
spiritually that truth has to be deeper
than accidents of culture and just mere
historical contingency is the fact that
somebody was born and
in Mesopotamia and not in China and got
a different language game and so
whatever is true there has to be
understood in universal terms about the
nature human psychology and and the
human mind okay so so another thing that
that I wanted to just point out
obliquely and then I want to return to
outlining maybe where we agree is that
one of the things that was really
shocking to me I would say was the the
my reading of what was originally Jane
Goodall's discovery about chimp behavior
you know because there is this idea that
was really rooted in Rousseau Ian's
thinking that the reason that people
committed atrocities in the service of
their group identity let's say their
tribal identity was because culture had
corrupted us so it was this uniquely
human thing but then of course Goodall
showed in the 1970s that the chimps at
Gombe I think that's been pronouncing
that correctly would go on raiding
parties right and so there'd be like
four or five adolescent chimps usually
male sometimes with a female in there
they would patrol the borders of their
territory if they found an interloper on
the border near the border from another
troop even if it was a member of their
troop that had emigrated so to speak and
that they that they had had some history
with they would tear them to pieces and
of course that was shocking to Goodall
but and and my understanding is she had
some trepidation about publishing it
although she did but then that's been
noted repeatedly in other forms of chimp
behaviors so see I've been really
interested in the Commission of atrocity
in the service of belief and it's
tempting to pin that say on on Dogma and
then to associate that with religious
dogma I think that's all tempting but
the fact that chimps do it shows that it
can't be a consequence of something like
religious belief unless you're willing
to say that the reason that chimps
commit atrocity in the service of their
troop and their territory is because
chimps are religious and so they're not
religious and they don't really hold a
secular totalitarian viewpoint but they
act out they still act out the atrocity
element that's characteristic of human
behavior and so to me that makes the
problem deeper than one of
mirror let's say surface statements
surface statements yeah yeah the
obviously the problem of primate
aggression which we've inherited along
with the chimps is deeper or at least
different than the problem of religious
violence or totalitarian political
structure is that okay get the worst out
of people so but we have we have these
primate capacities that we have to
correct for and we're busily trying to
correct for almost everything that we've
have been evolved to do and we're not we
you know we don't like the state of
nature for good reason and virtually
everything that's good about human life
is born of our I would argue culture
based and and you know highly
intelligent and necessary effort to to
mitigate what is in fact natural for us
and that immature there's nothing more
natural than tribal violence would you
love this or that you're describing
James okay so so then it also seems like
we agree that the the core element of
tribal alliance which would have its
roots say in the chimpanzee proclivity
to or its analog in the chimpanzee
proclivity to identify with the
dominance hierarchy of the troop is
something that's a source of the
proclivity for human social aggression
that's independent of it's at least an
independent of any obvious religious
substrate so there are other reasons for
group belief and the commission of
atrocity that can't be directly
attributed to to religious dogma yeah I
mean as and what most worries me about
religion I would say that obviously
religion
can channel these primate urges in
unhappy ways so you can get tribal
violence that gets amplified by
religious dogmatism and that should
trouble everyone but it's not unique to
religion it's also nationalism and it's
racism and it's all other kinds of
dogmatism but what most worries me are
those cases where clearly good people
who are not necessarily captured by
tribalism per se are doing the
unthinkable based purely on religious
doctrines that they believe
wholeheartedly with with
good evidence so you have the person who
joins Isis who wasn't even Muslim before
they converted you know 16 months ago
and they go all the way down the rabbit
hole to the the most doctrinaire most
committed most uncompromising view of
just how you have to live in this world
if you're going to be Muslim and they
join Isis based on the idea that
salvation only goes one way
and the dying and defends that the one
true faith is the best thing that can
happen to you there's no question that
they're individuals who have made that
journey in fact there are individuals by
the thousands who have made that journey
and there are far more benign versions
of that they're people who just waste
their lives I would argue converting to
whatever the belief system is and just
wasting a lot of time worrying about
hell or worrying about the fact that
their child is gay and the you know the
creator of the universe doesn't approve
of that and so there all kinds of
suffering that strike me as truly
unnecessary born not of again ape-like
urges but ideas that any rational person
would if believed what would follow to
that that same terminus I mean if the
thing is a if you buy if you buy the
fact again to take Islam as as a current
example if you buy the claim that the
Quran is the perfect word of the creator
of the universe and never to be
superseded by anything humanity does now
or a thousand years from now that
commits a rational / that then then the
exercise of human reason is bounded by
this I would argue pathological frame
which leads to certain outcomes that
should really worried us so so let's
take that claim apart for a minute
because that's not your claim
specifically that the claim that you
were describing see because that's
that's really not the claim that
religious fundamentalists make the claim
they make is worse than that because
they claim that the Quran say or the
Bible for that matter is the literal
word of God
but more than that they claim that their
understanding of that word is correct
which means they conflate two things
like because you could imagine a
situation where you had a book and I'm
not saying this is the case it's an
imaginative exercise where you had a
book that had all the answers that was
extraordinarily complicated and so that
when you read it it wouldn't be obvious
that you understood it or perhaps
wouldn't be obvious that you didn't
understand it either but you're not
going to be able to you can't get an
uninterpreted version of the book and so
the fundamentalist claim is far worse
it's that not only is there an absolute
reality truth embedded in the book but
that their particular take on that
absolute reality is the absolute take on
that book yeah so they can flate their
own they make an assumption of their own
omniscience and then pass that off onto
God yes except in their defense and I
don't often rise to the defense of
fundamentalism it's it's very easy to
get there because some of the claims in
the book are not at all hard to parse in
fact so many of them can only be
honestly interpreted in one way so to
take again an example that will be not
inflammatory to you but makes the point
it just says that the remedy for theft
in the Quran is to cut the hands off a
thief auuu that is the unambiguous
injunction it's not an allegory it's not
it's so so the you have to be you have
to indulge some kind of tortured
[Music]
interpretive scheme to avoid the the
shocking fact that the creator of the
universe
well thinks you should live this way for
all time and people like Isis I mean to
them and this is my claim it's just that
this is most of what is in these books
and this is what worries me about those
books because they can't be edited most
of what's in the books is clearly not
the best that humanity is capable of in
the ethical domain
or in this so and and so and so clearly
and that this is true for morality
you know most pressingly but it's true
for science is true for economics is
true for anything else that we are wise
to pay attention to so slavery is
condoned in the Bible in both Testaments
and in the Quran there's no getting away
from that now you can say well it's not
the central thrust of any of these books
but if you if you go to the books and
try to figure out what the creator of
the universe wants with respect to the
owning and needless and miseration of
other people right he expects you to
keep slaves and he's told you how to do
it you know don't knock out their eyes
and their teeth don't take if you're a
Muslim don't take other Muslims as
slaves but it's not an accident that the
people who joined Isis thought that it
was absolutely kosher to take slaves to
take sex slaves and I mean they were
even there their use of their sex slaves
was conducted as a sacrament and that's
not an accident may they work in rain
over there that they use 80 girls before
they raped them so this is not unlike
the what many people expect it's not
that this doctrine is being used as a
pretext for people who would otherwise
do terrible things like take sex slaves
and rape them
and so there's no net damage being done
here by this belief system no these are
I would argue in many cases
psychologically normal people who are
simply convinced of the absolute
veracity of these ideas and and in the
in this case that the perfect example of
Muhammad as the the most self actualized
human has ever existed and you know what
did Muhammad do Muhammad took sex slaves
so you know and he said and then then
once you
once you grant that and this is I mean
this is where you there's a tension
between you know how we pursue the same
goals like you know as we've just
established we have many of the same
goals but insofar as you make religion
look palatable insofar as you suggest to
your audience that they can they can
have their religious cake and eat it too
they can they can have their reason they
can have their respect for science they
can have a 21st century worldview but
they can also hold on to everything they
love than Christianity or fear to lose
it is undoubtedly mostly Christianity
but but whatever any religion my concern
is that it keeps us shackled to these
Iron Age philosophies and these Iron Age
conversations where we should be having
a 21st century conversation about
everything ethics included okay okay so
[Applause]
okay so but I want to ask you a little
bit about your feeling wait wait before
it before you move on I want to get each
of you to clarify something so that we
know where we are so Sam you said the
problem here is that the dogma can't be
updated right that slavery is with us
permanently because it's written into
the dogma but clearly most of the
traditions in which it's written into
the holy book don't practice slavery and
the people who who adhere to these
belief systems wouldn't defend slavery
so clearly there is the capacity for an
update mekinese but not really I mean
they've been forced it had beaten out of
them right I mean that we fought a civil
war in the u.s. to get rid of slavery
but was Christians who have bought
slavery in England though what was that
it was Christians who were at the
forefront of the movement to abolish
there are Christians on either side of
everything I mean there's no one else to
do a job but that's the update but but
it was specifically Christians who were
using their Christian belief as a
justification yes eradicate but the
problem was they were actually on the
losing side of a theological argument
and and it would be much better I think
you would agree if one of the Ten
Commandments had been don't keep slaves
I mean there's certainly one we could
swap out for that one and and so that
would have been much easier for
Christians to have fought against
slavery and it's it's much harder for
Muslims frankly to fight against it now
the problem is that there's a point I
made I think in my first book is that
the the doors leading out of this kind
of fundamentalism don't open from the
inside they get bashed open from the
outside and it's it's it's humanism and
it's secularism and it's scientific
rationality that has exerted such
pressure such winnowing pressure on
Christianity you know now for multiple
centuries that that's why we're not
encountering the Christians of the 14th
century on a daily basis the way don't
we and if we are essentially
encountering Muslims of the 14th century
a not only in the Middle East but in our
own
in in terms of their intuitions about
how we should all live right I mean the
fact that zero percent of UK Muslims
think homosexuality is acceptable right
zero percent me you there's almost no
question you can come up with where we
could pull this this this society and
say you know I mean do you think that
that the Lizard King is living in the
Oval Office you know that you never get
a zero percent response to any poll
question right but if you ask Muslims on
the streets of London is homosexuality
morally acceptable apparently you can
find no one who says it is that's
shocking and it's not an accident right
and it would be much easier if the book
actually said actually you can love
anyone you want and you know it's it's
not a problem it is shocking but I think
you know there's a reason that you keep
finding yourself that at Islam which may
be the slowest to update for reasons
that may be ancient but that's that's a
you that is useful well I can do it for
Christianity I just I want to make the I
want to make the point as cleanly and as
undistracted ly as possible but yeah
it's admit it's true I have the same
kinds of concerns about Christianity or
Mormonism or Scientology or anything
else and they're all at the point is
they're all different and there's no
reason to be because you know Islam to
take the case where it's fine
Islam doesn't represent any impediment
to stem-cell research
right and because they just don't think
that that the the the fertilized ovum is
immediately and sold they wait waits 40
days or 80 days or 120 days depending on
what hadith you believe so it's just
that never came up when we were all
complaining about how religion in this
case Orthodox Judaism and Christianity
and in the States was posing an
impediment to embryonic stem-cell
research okay okay so I wanted to ask
you a clarifying question - yeah sure in
Pope's same level would you agree that
there are things written into these
religious texts that are unambiguously
unacceptable viewed through a modern
lens and not because the texts are so
complicated that we
misunderstood something but there are
things that are just written in there
that we now understand to be wrong okay
so so the first thing the first thing I
would say is that we have to be very
careful about equating all the religious
texts and I do actually think that are
careful about that but that's something
we can have a discussion about so so
because you know for a lot of my life I
was I would say more interested in the
universal truths expressed in religious
belief across different cultures but
I've become more and more aware of the
important distinctions between the
religious cultures maybe in the last ten
years so it isn't clear to me that you
can just throw all religious dictum
dicta in the same bucket and there maybe
there's complex reasons for that so you
know and one question which you kind of
sent it Sam already is do you see a
hierarchy of unacceptability between
different religious doctrines I mean and
I would say act it okay fine fine fine
so okay now but here here's an
interesting issue and and I think we're
starting to zero in on we've covered
what we agree on a lot of it but there's
no answer Bret's question because I
think sorry sorry I answered the first
half of it but the second part is I
think that this is where I'm going to
sound like a postmodernist which I
really hate
I would say sentence by sentence yes
you're correct paragraph by paragraph
perhaps but here's here's the problem
with complicated texts especially ones
that actually constitute narratives so
in imagine imagine this so you imagine
you're at a movie and it's a movie with
a twist at the end and so the entire
movie is set up to make you think one
particular way and to have one set of
experiences but when you put the twists
in at the end it changes the entire
structure and so this is the one of the
complex problems that actually led to
the rise of postmodern interpretations
of literature which is that if you take
a complex narrative there's a very large
number of ways of interpreting it and it
isn't self-evident which of those are
canonically correct and we can deal with
that horrible issue later but but it's a
good objection and it's true and what it
does is it makes these sorts of things
quite complicated because in the the
Bible is a series of books and they had
influence on one another and they were
sequenced with a very complex editorial
process and there's actually a
developmental narrative that links all
the chapters together and what that
means this is at least I'm going to
speak from from the perspective or in
terms of analysis of the Christian Bible
what it means is that you have to read
the beginning as if it's also influenced
by the end which is what by the way and
in case you think that I'm weaseling
around here and I'm not is that that's
exactly what you do every time you read
any story any work of fiction you say
well you're not claiming that the Bible
is a work of fiction it's like don't
don't that's it that's just a cheap
objection that's not my point my point
is that it's a narrative and everything
in a narrative is conditioned by all the
rest of the things in the narrative and
it is well known like if you're a
screenwriter for example there's an old
dictum remember who generated was one of
the great Russians that if there's a
rifle lying on a table in the
first scene that it better be used by
the end of the second scene or it
shouldn't have been there at all so
there's this coherence I'm looking for
the rifle in your answer to this
question yeah I want to be used my point
is is that it isn't reasonable to take a
single sentence out of a coherent
narrative and say that stands on its own
or it's rarely reasonable because you
have to interpret the word in the
sentence and the sentence in the
paragraph and the paragraph in the
chapter and the chapter in the context
of the entire book you have to do that
now you could object and reasonably so
that there are some sentences that are
so blatant that you can't use context to
to what paraphrase them let's say but I
think you also have to give the devil
let's do that the Christian Bible is a
developmental narrative and the
beginning has to be read in light of the
end and that's a that's a that's is it a
fact so what does that do to Moses's
laws of war no this is not a narrative
this is instructions about what to do
when you invade a foreign land if you
intend to take over that land you kill
every break right there are other rules
in there about killing husbands and
taking the wives yeah this custom it's a
brutal document absolutely brutal and so
my point would be I don't know that
reading that portion in light of the end
even if you call the end of the New
Testament I don't know that it changes
Moses's laws of war and their
acceptability well hypothetically if you
take the New Testament seriously it does
because it's a suit it's a document that
supersedes it and I think there's
actually technical reasons doesn't
supersede it on every point I mean this
is a problem slavery is a very
straightforward case because clearly the
the the bible thumpers of the south who
were defending slavery with reference to
the text felt they were on firm ground
and i would just I would invite anyone
to read what the the New Testament and
the Old Testament say about slavery to
see that they were on fairly firm ground
that the the balance of the of the
honest reading was on the side of
clearly we can we can keep slaves right
Jesus Jean Jesus never envisioned a
world without slavery and he had ma
slaves to serve their masters well and
to serve their Christian masters
especially well English Protestants
wouldn't have agreed with that because
like I said they were at the forefront
of the fight against slave okay but I
think they're really influenced by
something outside the text and this is
begin is you're making this harder than
it is and my concern is why well I don't
think I am because I think that the
fundamental message in the New Testament
for example is that so that usually all
that if we so-so Jews are in possession
of a book that has some diabolical
passages that would be better left out
you're not going to offend it's not like
it's in the Old Testament itself in the
Jewish Bible there's there's also the
seeds of the same tension so for example
there's a tension and this would be a
tension that's of interest to you
because you you've stated quite clearly
in your book in in the moral landscape
that you don't want to throw the baby
out with the bathwater with regards at
least two religious phenomenology you
said that for example I still consider
the world's religions to be mere
intellectual runes maintained at
enormous economic and social cost but
now I understood that important
psychological truths could be found in
the rubble well I'm trying to find the
important psychological truths in the
rubble and so and so but we have to
decide also if we agree about that like
are there important psychological truths
to be found in the rubble oh absolutely
okay so with the problem with revelation
this notion of revelation this notion
that some books weren't written by smart
people they were written by God allows
you it confines you to take in the whole
text even though this text was cobbled
together over centuries and some four
whole centuries some books were in the
New Testament and then they got thrown
out the centuries later and some books
weren't in and then got put in so it's a
it's an all too human process that got
us these books in the first place but
once they were set the believers imagine
that you're stuck with every passage and
there are passages in the Old Testament
that tell you to stone a
or a woman who's not a virgin on her
wedding night take her to her father's
doorstep and stone her to death right
and where you can probably agree that
those are wrong so yeah there's another
point for greed only you don't have to
read the book to the end to know that
it's wrong you can get you can get that
from the paragraph yeah but that is what
I said I didn't say you had to read the
end to the end of the book to those
related to end you needed to read to the
end of the book to contextualize those
statements within the whole I didn't
there's no ace culpa Terry there's no
extra context as to those kinds of
statements and that's there is in the
Old Testament there's a real there's a
real tension and this is I think the
tension that would be of interest to you
is there's a tension between the
dogmatic and the prophetic traditions
and I think to the degree that you're
interested in religious phenomenology
you find yourself on the side of the
prophetic tradition and the prophetic
tradition has implicitly in it what
would you call an an implicit damnation
of those dogmatic crew those cruelly
dogmatic rules you see that emerge all
the time and well arguably in
Christianity I mean I think the only
Judean see clearly there in the Old
Testament once again to Islam but but
every prophetic I mean the notion of
prophecy is dangerous and worth worrying
about I mean the idea that any ancient
book contains in it a perfect
description of rightly interpreted
however difficult to interpret it if
you're only smart enough you could
extract from this text a perfect window
on to the future right and that that
whole generations of people have lived
by the lights of this cockamamie idea
right that the world is going to end and
it's ending is going to be glorious
right this is this is V at the center of
most in most eschatology it's just that
the when the wheels come off totally
right that's in some levels the best
thing that's ever gonna happen because
it's showing you that that in this case
Jesus is going to come back and throw
the sinners into a lake of fire and at
the sea I read I've read to the end of
the book it's pretty scary at the end as
well and the revelation is
yeah yeah you're kidding well let that
so that's a really good objection but
you know like when I did my lectures on
the Bible last year I said they provided
a psychological take on the biblical
lectures and that's what I'm going to
attempt to maintain here because I don't
believe that I'm qualified to make
fundamental metaphysical statements but
but you know that that that that the
scene that's that's delimited out at the
end of Revelation so that's a very
interesting book read psychologically
because what it anything this is we
should talk about well let me let me
just let me just address that only take
a minute to do it and I'll try to be
succinct so there's an idea that's
expressed in that book is that it's
something like things are always falling
apart in a fundamental manner it's part
it's built into the strut there's an
apocalyptic element to human life we
fail in small ways and we fail in
catastrophic ways and everything that we
have we lose and we die so there's and
and societies come to an end there's an
apocalyptic element built into the
structure of human reality and part of
part of what's revealed in that strange
book at the end which is like a
hallucinogenic nightmare in some sense
is that the hero is born at the darkest
point in the individual in the journey
and it's a psychological truth and it's
very very apt because at the darkest
point this is also why christ is born
near near the darkest time of the year
from from a from a metaphysical
perspective there's an idea there that
when things fall apart that's the time
for the birth of the hero and the hero
in Revelation is also the place where
free where we're truthful speech most
clearly manifests itself because in the
Christian tradition Christ is identified
with truthful speech and so the notion
there is that redemption under
apocalyptic conditions is to be found in
the revelation of truthful speech which
is something that you actually believe
well I believe in truthful speech but I
also believe that you can play this kind
of interpretive game with almost any
text this is this way of but then you
can do it with the world Sam and that
that wreaks havoc with your value from
facts argument no actually I didn't hear
what you just said what was that well I
said you can you can you could make
exactly the same object
with the world of facts is there's an
infinite number of facts and there's an
infinite number of potential
interpretations and so Pat tracking the
pathway from the fact to a value is
actually impossible it's the same
argument with regards to no occasion we
should talk about that but that I don't
think that's a good analogy I they're
more and less plausible interpretations
of any situation any data and any text
arguably but the problem is that you can
you can read into any story some
[Music]
apparently meaningful set of
psychological insights which but you can
do that with any set of facts - well no
I mean there are certain things you
can't you can't over interpret to your
heart's content and come out anyway you
choose my point is that the first of all
there are there this is why
fundamentalism always has an edge over
more quote more sophisticated theology
because the the sophisticated theology
is in in most cases inspired by a more
and more modern recognition that well we
can't read it literally because it
either makes no sense or it makes
barbaric sense right so we have to get
away from the literal and the more you
get away from the literal the more you
are unconstrained by the text and you
can just broadcast on it anything you
want to put there and so you know the
the literal X there's no question that
most generations of Christians who read
revelation expected the world to end in
some literal sense of this kind of
phantasmagoria I mean there was there
was gonna be a beast and it was I mean
this you know undoubtedly they thought
this was gonna happen in their own time
you know under Rome but this is a you
know if you're going to go purely
literary on any of these texts you are
on some level you're playing tennis
without the net you're unconstrained by
the text and you can do with
more or less anything you want isn't
that isn't that argument working at
cross-purposes with your other argument
well knows because it's always tempting
first of all there are lines that do not
announce there that they're susceptible
to that interpretation yes you can you
can say listen Allah does not want us to
cut the hands off of thieves he he just
you know he he he meant to cut the you
know the the hand of their volition
rather than their actual hands right so
you're constraining them rather than
kind of now sure undoubtedly there was
some some Muslim somewhere who wants to
interpret it that way but it gets harder
and harder the clearer that the the line
is and the problem with all of these
texts is that there are so many
principles again I mean since it read
revelation any way you want
it is still a problem that it it is
perfectly rational on the basis of
reading that text to expect the world to
end and for Jesus Jesus to be the only
Savior of it therefore if you know if
you happen to be born a Hindu or born
Muslim or born a Jew who doesn't
recognize Jesus to be the Messiah and
you are screwed well you know what turn
it it's a funny thing though I mean it's
a strange thing let's say that one of
the things we already agreed on as far
as I can tell is that the antidote to
pathological dogmatism is is free
truthful expression something like that
is that yeah okay yeah well but one of
the things I would say that's absolutely
crucial to Christianity in particular is
the notion that the thing that's
redeeming is exactly that and it doesn't
matter so it's a universal truth now if
we both agree on that the idea that the
free expression of truthful speech is
the antidote let's say both denialism
and to totalitarianism then the notion
that that might be embodied in something
like the word which is truly I think the
deepest of Christian ideas is that why
is how is that not the same claim now
let me elaborate it more a little bit
more
or completely so here here's the strange
thing first of all I agree with you by
the way about the danger of flying off
the text right about as you move away
from the text
your interpretation gets less and less
constrained and I think it's also the
same danger as move of moving away from
the facts which is I think why you want
to ground values and facts so I get that
argument I think it's accurate but here
but here's here's something strange is
that this notion that redemptive that
Redemption is to be found in truthful
speech is actually embodied in Christian
mythology let's say as a personality and
not as an idea it's actually something
that you embody and act out it's not
just an idea and that's why there's an
emphasis on the idea of the embodiment
of the word in flesh it's a very
sophisticated idea I mean it's it's an
insanely sophisticated idea so and they
will and there's one more thing and then
okay so look you you you've made the
case and I hope we can really get to
this because this is the really tough
part of our discussion I think is that
you want to ground the world of values
in something that's true we could say
objectively true but let's just say true
for a minute and I share that desire but
but the problem is is that I can't see
and you actually state this in your book
I can't see how you can interpret the
world of facts without an a priori
interpretive structure and and this is
an old philosophical claim it's not
unique to me it's it's the claim of
conte for example that you can't get
directly from the fact to the value
because there's an interpretive
framework that mediates between you and
the facts and so first of all I'd like
to know if you accept that proposition
and then the second question would be if
you do accept the proposition then
what's your understanding of the nature
of the interpretive framework because I
think it's best understood at least in
part as a personality or as a story for
that matter so well I think our
intuition of truth the the intuition
that there's a difference between fact
and fiction or fact and fantasy the
intuition that we are in we live in
relationship to a common reality
which our understanding can converge
provided we're looking in the same
direction with the same tools I think
that is certainly deeper than religion
it's not best captured by stories it's
it even if it even if you could as a
matter of historical fact point to its
roots in story and myth and religion
that's not an argument that it's now in
the 21st century best captured by story
and myth and religion I think it's it is
a fundamental intuition to which our
sanity both personally and inter
subjectively is anchored I mean to lose
a sense of objective reality is to lose
the the platform on which you can
communicate with anyone and or
rationally expect anything to happen a
moment from now to think that your
memory represents something about a
prior state of the world and your
beliefs represent something about a
possible state in the future all of this
is anchored to a sense that there's a
difference between knowing something
really and just imagining it
right there's a difference between
perception and hallucination and all of
these distinctions are born of this this
intuition I think we do have clearly we
have fundamental intuitions which are
either impossible to analyze or can be
analyzed with respect to only other
intuitions which we did which we deem
more rudimentary with upon which
everything else we do as a matter of
knowledge gathering and sense making is
built so the intuition that 2+2 makes
for right you know you at some point you
learn basic arithmetic and you learn
what addition is and it's demonstrated
to you with objects and you show it
you're shown you take two apples and you
take two more apples and then you have
four apples look just count them the the
intuition that that can be generalized
to any four objects right that it's not
just a fact about
right this is something that we are
clearly designed to have there are
places where it might break down right
they might break down and you know the
quantum level it might break down and in
areas where our intuitions fail we
recognize those failures in science and
mathematics by recourse to other
intuitions which again are unanalyzed
able but so there is just this fact that
we do pull ourselves up by our
bootstraps hmm and that's not
embarrassing okay so what's the
difference between what's that and I'm
not trying to trap you here seriously
not so so there might be mathematical
intuitions a priori let's say Kant
identified time and spaces in a prior
intuitions but I think there's a third
category of a prior intuitions that are
in fact stories or their personalities
or stories so let me give you an example
so I'm gonna do a quick rereading of the
moral landscape so because see you talk
about GE moore's argument of infinite
regress if you claim that something's
good and you equate it with something
you can also ask infinitely why the
thing you're equating it with is good
now it seems to me that the way that you
step out of that argument and correct me
if I'm wrong here is you tell this you
tell us you tell a story I'm not trying
to be smart about that you tell two
stories you tell a story about someone
who has an absolutely terrible life
there in a in a jungle where nature is
trying to kill them all the time and
well they're trying to be killed by
nature while nature is trying to kill
them all the time horrible barbaric
thugs are making their life miserable in
every possible way okay so that's one
poll let's say and then another poll you
identify and these are hypotheticals so
I guess they're fictions that's one way
of thinking about it even though they're
extracted from real situations they're
there they're met have fictions they're
meta truths that's another way of
thinking about it you contrast a good
life and you know that's a life where
the person has enough to eat and enough
shelter and you know they have the
things that you would expect people to
want you say this is a bad life and you
say this is a good life and so and then
you say that's and then you make a side
move which I would say is that that's an
objectively verifiable fact
I would say I don't think it is an
objectively verifiable fact I think it's
a fundamental moral claim and I think
that's where you put your stake in the
ground and I would say when I read that
I thought well if you take your jungle
story which you've extracted from a
bunch of Horrors and compiled and you
take your positive story which you've
extracted from a bunch of horrors or a
bunch of quasi utopias let's say and
compiled you're two-thirds of the way to
a landscape of Hell in heaven right well
so then why not continue the abstraction
and say look what we're really trying to
avoid here is hell
oh yeah we're really trying to move
towards this heaven yeah but oh yeah but
well no as soon as we do that you might
name it just landscape no but my name
for hell is it's very interesting
because like we're talking about this at
dinner we're talking about this at
dinner and how that would be the overlap
or lack of overlap between our audiences
and so like I just heard from your
audience there and
you might have heard from the odd
convert but but what's amazing to me is
so like I have to do some work to figure
out what point they think you made and I
said if you're gonna produce a fiction
oh I don't go right to the end okay so
did produce a fiction it's you you can
tell stories by way of communicating
certain ideas I mean that's obviously so
I'm not saying stories aren't incredibly
powerful and useful and inevitable right
it's like we we you wait I think you are
you're not saying you might not be
saying that they're that they're they're
no they're not inevitable but you are
debating their utility and power because
you know you said that you don't need
this story as an intermediate now we
have a few doors open here which I think
we should okay we should extract the
most out of these areas that we've
touched and not run on something else oh
okay I I think there's two talked about
the utility of story right which is
obviously a fact about the world about
human psychology that you're reading a
lot into and more into that I'm reading
right and the people we just heard from
love that you well maybe I'm reading
more into it than you are but you talk a
lot about the primacy of stories and
you're trying to get me to admit that
they are that I even I helplessly resort
to storytelling to make my points right
well you think I think this is a good
place for us to it and I don't want us
to get bogged down but I think it's a
good place for us to touch this topic of
the distinction between literal and
metaphorical truth what you I mean you
might want to introduce it but I because
that in my mind that covers this there's
different emphasis on stories okay
briefly but we are we are at we are at
60 minutes and we had read to go an hour
and 15 before we start QA so I agree
that metaphorical truth is relevant here
metaphorical truth is my argument that
there are some things which are
literally false but if you behave as if
they were true you come out
ahead of where you would if you behaved
according to the fact that they are
false and so that these things hover in
a kind of intermediate space to call
them false is incorrect right and I hear
Jordan wanted to call them true because
they're so useful right but you also
call look this is what happens in the
moral landscape I think tell me that
tell me why I'm wrong because I'm really
trying to understand it see I think you
dealt with GE Moore's problem of
infinite regress by by staking a moral
proposition and your moral proposition
was look here's a way things can be
horrible and here's the way things can
be good can we accept that this is
horrible and this is good and that we
should move towards good and if the
answer is yes we can accept that then we
can proceed and maybe we can even
proceed with extracting values from
facts but we have to accept that a
priori presupposition first and you
insist that we have to accept it because
it's objectively true and I don't think
that's clearly so so the limit is get
that proposition clear so my argument is
that the worst possible misery for
everyone is bad that's hell okay that's
so so hell is is the religious version
of that but I'm just you can forget
about religion or whether there's a God
or anything else that we live in a
universe that admits of the possibility
of experience I'm asking you to imagine
a universe where every conscious mind
every mind that can have an experience
is tuned to the worst possible
experience for that mind for as long as
possible so there's no silver lining
there's no there no lessons learned
everything that can suffer suffers as
much as it possibly can for as long as
it can now that includes human beings
includes animals and includes the future
AI that we might build that can suffer
it includes beings that we'll never know
about right so my argument is that's bad
if anything is bad that's bad okay we
don't disagree that the hell is bad if
the word bad
is going to mean anything that's better
you can't say that's fine but it's not a
factual no it is it's a factory it's a
claim about so I would argue to you and
again if this it's it's hard to impart
this intuition if someone doesn't share
it but if someone doesn't share this
intuition I have no way of interpreting
any other other word that comes out of
their mouth after they admit they don't
share this so episode just imagine
someone saying and that doesn't make it
a factual claim so again you guys are
gonna get stuck here and I think give us
give us one more minute
okay one more minute because I don't
think we'll get stuck here every claim
every claim we make about anything at a
certain point if you trace all the tools
were using down to you know Turtles all
the way down to something that we can't
explain and justify right this is true
of physics it's true of mathematics I
just said it was true of arithmetic good
ole proved it's true of arithmetic I
mean there's that we have intuitions of
truth that can't be cashed out by
recourse to the system itself and it's
true morally I would argue in this sense
that yes the worst possible misery for
everyone is bad and if you're gonna say
well okay well who knows maybe it's good
what I had what does that mean what a
bad means bad again you guys are gonna
get stuck okay what does bad I really I
really think that we're gonna go down a
rabbit hole here okay this is a crucial
issue that should absolutely why you get
stuck
all right so we're putting our we have a
mutiny here we're at war with our
moderator yes give us two more minutes
because okay all so so so let me but let
what I mean honestly by the way I have a
prediction that in here two minutes we
won't be any further okay let's bet I'll
bet you a bet you a dollar
you're literally playing devil's
advocate here because you don't believe
that it's that hell might be good no of
course okay I didn't say that so you
agree that it's bad this isn't I would
argue that anything you would if you're
going to use the word bad and good yeah
or better and worse or anything any make
any value judgment about anything it
will implicit in those judgments will be
an acknowledgment whether you're going
to acknowledge it or not when I put the
question to you that the worst possible
misery for everyone is bad you can't use
the word bad unless you're disagreeing
in the least about that okay so it's
built into your good and bad in with
respect to every other situation in life
fine you know like you know if you if
you're going home tomorrow and you're
you know a bus drives by and cuts your
hand off and you say well that was bad
it only makes sense with reference to
this underlying claim well it would be
worse if the other hand got cut off too
and everyone's hands got cut off you're
beating a dead horse here man I agree
with you so I'm saying that everyone
assumes this whether they whether they
claim to or not
okay okay and so and so to say and this
is this is how I bring GE Moore's
argument to end yeah he says his
argument depends on it being
intelligible at that point to say well
is that really bad is it really bad okay
well what would really bad be if if the
worst possible misery for everyone
didn't get you there right that there's
no there's no other space to occupy I'm
also not disputing the utility of your
move to bring GE Moore's infinite
regress to an end I'm disputing
something very specific
I'm disputing the issue that that's a
factual claim that's all well you know
is bad
is we should avoid it it brings mores
infinite regress to an end all of that I
agree it's deeper than a factual claim
it's just a claim about the is it's a
claim that is required to make any value
judgment intelligible right any value
judgment so it's like it's not an it's
not an arithmetic all claim so an
aeromedical claim about addition in this
case is is now you could say you could
say the same thing you could say when I
say two plus two makes four you could
say but is that a factual claim and
there's some way of jiggering the way
you talk about facts with respect to
mathematics where I could say well it's
not a factual claim but it's an
arithmetic alene it's a mathematical
claim well I'm also not trying to just
don't see you need to [ __ ] eyes or yep
fine what I'm trying to do is to what
I'm really trying to do we need see the
the the problem I have with your
argument and this isn't I don't mean
that you're wrong I see what you're
doing and I see why you're doing it and
as far as I can tell it's laudable but
for the problem is is that as far as I
can tell there's problems it doesn't
solve and there's other problems that
leaves on address that don't have to be
unsolved or unaddressed and so and one
of the problems is this problem of the
intermediary interpretive structure and
you you already said we need intuitions
to guide our our interrelationship with
facts because we've already agreed on
that so the question is what are the
nature of these intuitions and I'm
saying some of those intuitions take the
place of stories take the form of
stories but even more than that
so I'm gonna go after the hell thing
again okay because you said well it's
bad and you made sure that I also agree
with that which I do I agree with that
and then it's a point of profound
agreement between you and I like I've
spent my entire life trying to
understand why people did the worst
things they could possibly imagine
in the service of their dogmatic beliefs
and so I think that that's not good
seriously and I'm no fan of moral
relativism so we're on this we're in the
same page there now but what I noticed
it in when you wrote the moral landscape
is you you tell it and I'm not trying to
trap you you you tell a story about
it looks to me like it's a story about
heaven versus hell essentially let me
use that language momentarily but it's
also a story about good versus evil and
this is why it's because the question is
what's bad about Hell now you say the
suffering it's like fair enough man true
enough but not true but not true enough
so in what's what's also bad about Hell
in addition to the suffering the actions
that put you there the malevolence that
generates okay with that that's part of
the suffering so I mean oh no it's not
no it's not it's not the same as the
suffering it's not it's not the having
your hand cut off it's the pleasure
that's derived by the person who cut it
off that's more so but that's part of my
picture well but wait it's an important
the distinction the distinction is
important but also my my depiction but
Jordan my picture of the moral landscape
includes all of this it includes
everything that and this is why I don't
readily answer to the name of
utilitarian or consequentialist because
the way those those views tend to be
taught they tend to take as in the in
the tally of consequences you leave out
the psychological implications of being
the sort of person who would who would
have sought those consequences or
behaved that way right so I would grant
you and this I'm explicit about this
whenever I talk about this that part of
the picture of any consequentialist
discussion of well-being are is
everything about the human mind and
social relationships and societies born
of all the individuals living together
everything there that leads to different
states of consciousness so it's like you
having you having negative intentions
towards other people that give you that
produced certain negative actions in the
world they those intentions themselves
are part of the consequential picture
those intentions themselves lead that
closed the door to certain kinds of
positive mental states that you don't
have let's say you let's say you don't
have compassion
because you wake up every morning just
trying to figure out how to manipulate
people well not not being able to feel
compassion for other people is a bad
thing for many reasons we could adduce
and yet the usual consequentialist
picture just looks at what's happening
out in the world in terms of the body
count and that's not you know that's i
it's all part of this picture it's all
we're all talking anything that can
possibly affect a conscious mind
anywhere is part of the picture that i'm
painting that i'm calling the moral
landscape okay so you okay I want you I
want you to let me step in I I think I
can we need to we need to bring you guys
you know somewhere all right I'm gonna
start with you Sam let's swap out the
idea of metaphorical truth for something
a little harder headed heuristics right
we have heuristics we use them to
perceive the world they're often highly
reliable in fact almost everything that
you believe that lets you operate has to
be a heuristic of some kind I mean if
you decided to learn to drive and you
got into the car and they said okay well
it's all quarks out there right you need
to understand how quarks interact with
each other not useful right not useful
right what you need are some heuristics
in which you can stipulate that there's
something called a vehicle out there and
you don't have to be overly precise
about what it is and you learn to avoid
it okay the heuristics vary a lot in
quality some of them are really good the
periodic tables are really good okay the
idea of gravitational potential energy
is kind of crappy right if I have a
phone on a table here I can tell you how
much potential energy it has by
measuring its mass and its distance from
the ground but if I've got a whole one
depth on one side of the table and
another depth on the other side of the
table
I can't calculate it because it's a
crappy heuristic works well enough in
regular stuff right now here's the
question what if these religious texts
are heuristics through which most people
simplify calculations that they are in
no position to do based on the limited
amount that they are capable of
perceiving the amount that they
understand about the things that are in
play so they're deploying these
heuristics maybe to redo
things that degrade well-being if it
were true that religious heuristics
increased well-being by allowing people
to actually on average operate in the
world in a way that that increased
well-being what would you say about them
that well I would worry much less about
them obviously and that's why I don't
treat all religions equally and their
religions I literally never think about
because I'm not seeing the daily
casualties of those belief systems so
but you say that as people get away from
fundamental versions of these things and
I'm not advocating for fundamentalism
here which you say yourself as people
get away from the fundamental versions
of these things things tend to go
haywire and so in its in essence what
you're saying is well we tend to go
haywire in what sense well I thought I
was in term multiplicity of
interpretations right well yeah but so
people are in that's the researchers
better or heuristics and I think the
pressure is some of these heuristics are
obviously so bad that there's there's
civilizational pressure to find better
interpretations and but you said that
the fundamentalists have an advantage
yes
what is that advantage because if you
just go back to the text and say listen
I just want to I want to understand what
these words mean right you get at the
first pass the literal interpretation
right and you're not bringing the the
any armamentarium you've brought your
view you've got from the outside from
other parts of culture to parse the text
you're just trying to really if it's in
English and you speak English you're
you're just trying to decode the words
right right and when it says if you're
if you're the girls not a virgin on her
wedding night take her to her father's
doorstep and stone her to death
that you know what stone means you know
what girl means you know what father
means and you're you're 90% there to an
obvious atrocity I get the horror of it
and we'll get to that in a second yeah
but but the basic point is to say that
the fundamentalists have an advantage is
to acknowledge something funky
about those stories which I'm claiming
are going to be some kind of
evolutionary heuristic for living a life
though that mayhem defensible they have
you know they have an event it's not an
advantage that it's an advantage it's
it's a memetic advantage it's an
advantage Isis has the advantage when
when the people who share their
interpretation of Islam they have you
know it's like it's it's why someone
like you know Anwar al-aulaqi could
could make youtube videos that so many
people found compelling it's because
it's it's totally straightforward it's
like the advantages listen that a lot of
people spend a lot of time lying to you
about what these books mean and what the
Prophet and how he lived right I you you
you know in your heart that my
interpretation of this is correct you
just read the words right and there's a
strength in that there's it there's an
honesty in that there's a there's a it's
just it's clear when it says sacrifice a
goat goat means goat right like you
don't have to do something else to make
goat means having nothing to do with
goat right and so that it's it's an ace
it's an asymmetric war of if you're
gonna try to make your dogmas more and
more palatable by importing stuff that
clearly was never even in the worldview
of anyone who birthed these religions
you're playing you're not doing that
because you want to live even more by
God's Word no you found some of God's
words unacceptable right and that's and
every spunda Mentalist can sniff that
out and they're right to sniff it out
because in fact either it is in fact the
motivation okay good so I think we have
we've got a tenuous kind of agreement
that there might be some kind of utility
that that utility might be morally
questionable sometimes but that there is
some reason that people would resort to
a fundamental simple interpretation
because as they depart from that
interpretation things get more difficult
and it creates some kind of disadvantage
well the part of the problem with that
would be that as you move away from the
text you you fractionate the moral
belief system and you end up with a
nihilistic situation so as you move away
from the
avant ism you move towards the parallel
danger which is moral relativism and
nihilism and so hopefully you can find
some balance so let me ask you know I
want to ask you a question
oh yes okay and also what time do we
actually start this party it's 10:00 I
just missed the time card but I think we
have another couple of minutes okay okay
so there's no objective reality at a
time I think hahaha actually it's a
pretty good conversation we could have
but so here's my question for you is if
we agree that there is some way in which
religious texts carry some kind of value
because they allow people to figure out
how to navigate their lives in ways that
might reduce suffering reduce the
complexity of the choices that they have
to make presumably you will agree that
that would be consistent with an
evolutionary interpretation that the
fact that the stories themselves are yes
functional would provide an advantage to
those who were deploying them yes so
here's the problem isn't it then also
true that those stories are responsive
to past environments and so the claim
that these things might be timeless
would be suspect and yes that you would
expect a spectrum of durability some
stories would be right in a brief moment
as okay oh that's true oh that's true so
far so good
well so far so good this is this is
actually I think quite excellent then
because what we have is a recognition
that there is something to these belief
systems that has to do with practical
realities in the past and we also have
an acknowledgment that we cannot trust
in these things based on simple faith
because even if they are can be certain
to have worked at some point in the past
we don't know what their relevance is to
the present right okay fair enough
like
that's and I would say that's that's two
things about that that's exactly why
we're having this discussion and you see
what happens in the most profound of
such texts is the idea that the process
by which your knowledge is updated has
to occupy a position in the hierarchy of
values that supersedes your reliance or
Dogma is the fundamental claim that's
why for example in Christianity the
notion is is that the word is the
highest of values and that's the
embodied word and that's the thing that
mediates between order and chaos and
everything else has to be subject to
that and I would say that's not a claim
that's unique to Christianity so for
example okay no I think I think we I
think because we're we were being told
we're out of time here so I want to give
Sam his reaction to that as well and
then we'll move on to Q&A
well I'm tempted to just ask Jordan a
question here this it's hard to know
what to save for tomorrow night but I
feel like we've got 3,000 people sitting
here who would really like an answer to
this question you say you believe in God
you have been no I say I act as if he
exists you say what I say I act as if he
exists so a much more precise claim okay
so then what what but in this case what
fits it so you act as though God exists
and in addition I've heard you say that
I act as though God exists that I can't
realize so far it's a yes yes we'll see
that the night is young
[Applause]
so in that sense I'm not really an
atheist I've heard you say this so that
some of you is well if I were really an
atheist I would be far more poorly
behaved than in fact I am right I would
be like we're Skolnick off committing
murders and and assuming there was
nothing wrong with more it would be more
likely yes yeah okay so so that's a big
distinction no more likely what was that
that's a big distinction that you would
is very different than it would be more
likely taking the safety off the gun
it's not the same thing you're shooting
it right yes the temptations laid open
to Raskolnikov would be more at hand
okay just as they were to him so what in
that so you know in what sense do you
mean well what is the God that you act
as though he she it exists and what is
that what what is the God shaped thing I
must have in my life to prevent me from
being a quote real atheist well okay
first of all I have to point out that
there's no possible way I can answer
both those questions in two minutes
well it's the same question I mean what
is it like what what do you mean by God
okay well I'm going to tell you some of
the things that I mean by God we do have
to get the questions we're gonna do this
tomorrow maybe this is where we start
well that was a pretty resentment now it
seems like that constitutes an audience
question wouldn't you say I tell you
what I tell you what let's
let's do this but let's be deliberate
about time okay
okay okay well I'm going to read some
things that I wrote because it's so
complicated that I'm not sure that I can
just spin it off the top of my head and
so you'll have to excuse me so and what
I'm going to do is sort of paint a
picture by by by highlighting different
things so now I already made one point
here I mean I made the point that part
of the conception of God that underlies
the Western ethos is the notion that
whatever God is is expressed in truth
the truthful speech that rectifies
pathological hierarchies and that isn't
all it does it also confronts the chaos
of being itself and generates habitable
order that's a that's the metaphysical
proposition and that that's best
conceptualized as at least one element
of God and so I would think about it as
a transcendent reality that's only
observable across the longest of
timeframes the longest of iterated time
frames to your point so so okay so
here's here's some propositions and
they're complicated and they need to be
unpacked so I'm just gonna read them and
you that'll have to do for the time
being so God is how we imaginatively and
collectively represent the existence and
action of consciousness across time as
the most real aspects of existence
manifest themselves across the longest
of timeframes but are not necessarily
apprehensible as objects in the here and
now so what that means in some sense is
that you have conceptions of reality
built into your biological and
metaphysical structure that a
consequence of processes of evolution
that that occurred over unbelievably
vast expanses of time and that structure
your perception of reality in ways that
it wouldn't be structured if you only
lived for the amount of time that you're
going to live and that's also part of
the problem of deriving values from
facts because you're evanescent and and
you can't derive the right values from
the facts that portray themselves to you
in your lifespan which is why you have a
biological structure that's like 3.5
billion years old so God is that which
eternally dies and is reborn in the
pursuit of higher being and truth that's
a fundamental element of here
mythology God is the highest value in
the hierarchy of values that's another
way of looking at it God is what calls
and what responds in the eternal call to
adventure God is the voice of conscience
God is the source of judgment and mercy
and guilt God is the future to which we
make sacrifices and something akin to
the transcendental repository of
reputation here's a cool one if you're
an evolutionary biologist God God God is
that which selects among men in the
eternal hierarchy of men so you know men
arrange themselves into hierarchies and
then men rise in the hierarchy and
there's principles that are important
that determine the probability of their
rise and those principles aren't
tyrannical power there's something like
the ability to articulate truth and the
ability to be competent and the ability
to make appropriate moral judgments and
if you can do that in a given situation
then all the other men will vote you up
the hierarchy so to speak and that will
radically increase your reproductive
fitness and the operation of that
process across long expanses of time
looks to me like it's codified in
something like the notion of God the
Father it's also the same thing that
makes women men attractive to women
because men women peel off the top of
the male hierarchy the question is what
should be at the top of the hierarchy
and the answer right now is tyranny as
part of the patriarchy but the real
answer is something more like the
ability to use truthful speech and the
service of let's say well-being and so
that's that's something that operates
across tremendous expanses of time and
it plays a role in the selection for
survival itself which makes it a
fundamental reality Jordan if I can just
cut in here with one question stop with
that for now
what
[Music]
so I was not hearing in that list of
attributes a God who could care if
anyone masturbated I was not hearing a
God who depends on what else is stopping
you from doing Sam well I'm sorry I miss
that I said it depends on what else it's
stopping you from doing well yeah okay
so it's it's important to do something
other than masturbate yes yes which is
which which actually constitutes a
problem which is harder than it sounds
I'm not hearing a god a personal God who
can possibly hear anyone's prayer is
much less answer them right and I've
talked is I'm wondering what percentage
of religious people who would say oh
yeah I believe in God and it's the most
important thing in my life what
percentage of those religious people do
you think have in mind a God of the sort
you just described I don't know Sam it's
a good question because when I go talk
to people would I when I talk to people
online and use exactly this terminology
millions of people listen so it's not so
obvious which what percentage of the
people see it this way it's maybe that
they have the intuitions but they
haven't been articulated well I mean
this is this is the problem this is what
worries me about this so yeah I mean you
you could do the same thing with the
idea of ghosts right so so people
traditionally have believed in ghosts
it's a it's an archetype you might say
the ghost survival of death is certainly
in archetypes and we know what most
people most of the time mean when they
say they believe in ghosts and I say I
don't believe in ghosts and you say no
no you you do believe in ghosts ghosts
are your relationship to the unseen
that's a ghost so you have a new
definition of ghost that you're putting
in the place provided which I have to
say well of course I have a relationship
to the unseen so yeah I guess I do
believe in ghosts you know
win that argument but that simply isn't
what most people mean by a ghost mostly
you mean use that simplified argument
vote you might consent but ghost as an
analogy for the proposition that I just
put forces what I see you do I mean
maybe you have more to say on the topic
of God but this is what I hear you doing
with God you have defined the God that
most people believe in and we know this
is the God that most people I was asked
what God I believed in yes no man I'm
asking you what percentage yes but you
you by shifting the the definition you
have robbed the the noun the traditional
noun of its traditional meaning and
you're giving you're imparting to people
yes wait a second wait a second I'm not
so she mean by traditional meaning look
it's one of the one of the elemental
claims in the old testament is that
you're not even supposed to utter the
name of God because by defining it too
tightly you lose its essence and so
let's not be talking about what the
classical definition of God is here okay
it's a historical non-starter okay
there's plenty hold on I can I check in
with the audience is the audience all
right with us continuing down this road
okay so
tonight can I jump in your sacrifice
your Q&A so yeah that it isn't the
expense of Q&A that's that's what you're
giving up but I think it's probably
worth it so let me say Sam I do not
believe in a supernatural God but the
God that I've heard Jordan just
described I do not have any difficulty
understanding why he might care if you
masturbate and I also don't have any
trouble figuring out how he might answer
prayers well well tell me more then well
I I can tell you I can tell you I can
tell you how a prayer might be answered
okay these are no specifics so so it'll
be interesting so I'm not Jordan we've
not talked about this if I heard an
answer from him that actually would
satisfy me as to what the mechanism of
action might be that that'd be pretty
interesting and if he can tell me what I
heard I think it would it would suggest
that that we're not just making up
stories you can so you might like this
you may be doing but well it's possible
okay so imagine that okay so let's
imagine that hellish situation that you
laid out okay but but let's let's put
the extra twist in it because one of the
things that we both decided I think was
that you also have to build in the
intent into that so let's say the hell
that we're talking about isn't the
victim of the terrible massacres that
you you laid out in the jungle story but
a perpetrator okay so someone who's
actually acted in a malevolent manner
truly malevolent manner okay or maybe
perhaps who wouldn't have to take that
extreme case we could say well perhaps
you've decided that any of you you've
decided that you've seriously done
something wrong okay and that you you
want to get away from Hell you want to
make things better
okay so here's here's an exercise you
can try so what you do is is as you sit
on the edge of your bed and you say okay
what I did was wrong and you have to
really believe this right so you've
thought about it's killing you it's
killing you it's now you're penitent and
you're confessing let's say
and you're confessing to yourself as
much as to anyone and you say I really
want to know what I did wrong and I
really want to know what I could do to
put it right and I'm willing to accept
any answer that will manifest itself to
me try that see what happens well that's
a prayer that will be answered and it
won't be answered in the way that you
want it to be answered I can bloody well
tell you that okay but but that what are
you communicating with are you
communicating with will you know that
that is something that that is a process
that I'm familiar with
it doesn't require any supernatural
explanation and it certainly it
certainly doesn't require that many
imagine that any of our books were
dictated by the creator of the universe
I didn't say that it acquired any secret
nobody nor didn't require the my concern
I was asked to provide an instance of
prayer that worked and that's what I did
but neither than that that's that's
fully understandable in terms of human
psychology it's not understandable
because we don't know where the answer
comes from well we don't know where
anything comes from that's true yeah
okay so yeah but that doesn't that
doesn't open the door one thing we can
know with absolute certainty said that
whoever wrote the Bible didn't know
either and there's many other things he
or she didn't know like everything else
we know scientifically right it's not
it's not so obvious whether people know
when they don't no one even knew the
brain was involved in any of this right
so yeah but as much as we do about how
the brain was involved in it but we've
already we've already established in
some tenuous way that things that nobody
understands could have evolved into
these stories in some way that would be
useful but nobody knew what they were
writing when they wrote it right but the
problem is that you can so again with
this has been focused through the lens
of your attachment to Christianity
largely
but the Hinduism Hinduism is a
completely different set of stories
right now and many of them the logic the
emotional logic the psychological import
many of them have the
opposite valence from any Christian
story you would tell the like for
instance the whole notion of good and
evil yeah right which has such primacy I
mean you talk about religion being
deeper than ethics because ethics just
deals with right and wrong and religion
deals with good and evil right at
bedrock okay good and evil do not have
the same meaning in the East Buddhism
and Hinduism do something very different
with living I'm willing to accept your
definitions of good and evil for truth
is just not even evil is just ignorance
on some level it's just evil is just you
haven't met any real evil people if you
believe that well okay so then all the
Hindus and Buddhists are wrong about
this that's that's a that's a possible
claim I'm just saying that there there's
over a billion people who have a
religious system of stories from which
they derive all kinds of meaning yep to
which they're mightily attached to where
we could play the same game of
archetypal interpretation and valuing
and yet you that the the cash value with
respect to good and evil is is
irreconcilable with what you get
Christianity look well but it doesn't it
doesn't have to be interoperable right
well but but in a reality presumably
Hinduism is also useful that's a set of
heuristic as to be for Hindus and if
Hinduism as a matter of doctrine and as
a matter of the interpretations of the
heuristics by the devout in both systems
if Hinduism and Christianity are
irreconcilable right then there must be
a deeper level of reality that explains
why they both work that can't be
reducible to Christianity being true or
Hinduism being true yeah that's a look
Sam that's a there's there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that objection like
so this is one of the immense problems
obviously that that actually leads down
the road to the kind of nihilism that
you were objecting to in in in the moral
landscape it's like one of the things
that Nietzsche said was it was it's very
much apropos to this is that you know
it's one thing to have your your belief
system shattered by the observation that
there are other belief systems that are
in commencer that seem to have equal
utility so that that's but it's even
worse is that once you make the
observation that there are other belief
systems that that have equal utility
then it can shatter your belief in
belief systems themselves and then
you're in the postmodern nihilist
landscape and that's a big problem or
you could just be in a more fundamental
landscape that subsumes both of those
losses that's fine let's hope that that
can happen but that I would say that's
the landscape that I'm trying to pursue
now you said that this is that I've been
approaching this safe from from a
Christian perspective in this dialogue
and to some degree that's true but there
are reasons for that but I would also
say I'm also doing what you recommend
doing because in maps of meaning for
example because you said well what about
this problem of multiple interpretations
of you can road maps of meaning what's
that you wrote maps of meaning I wrote
them all and sorry I must have missed
sorry I must have missed but what I
tried to do well I tried to address that
problem seriously like it's a really big
problem that it's the problem of
multiple interpretations
it's the postmodern problem is that
there's an infinite number of potential
interpretations okay so also what do we
do about that
and the answer is it's something you
allude to I'm sorry in in the moral
landscape and and it's part of the basis
of your argument why these things need
to be grounded in facts so because that
is part of the the answer to the problem
of an infinite number of interpretations
in maps of meaning I tried to do what al
Wilson recommended but this was before
he wrote his book I tried to use a
conciliation evil is systems I looked at
Christianity I looked at evolutionary
biology I looked at philosophy I looked
at neuroscience
and I looked at the literature on
emotion and motivation and and in the
literature on play that was very nicely
delineated by Piaget and I tried to see
where there was a pattern that repeated
across all dimensions of evaluation
which is exactly what you do for example
when you use your five senses to detect
something real in the world and that's
what Wilson recommended was a
conciliation was if it manifests itself
here and here and here and here and here
six places and it's always the same
pattern than the probability that that
pattern exists independent of my
delusional interpretation is radically
decreased yeah my claim however is that
many of these things don't repeat in
fact they're they're flipped around
completely based on different religious
assumptions and different cultures and
again I mean yeah I would just argue
this is trying to dispense with those
but I'm just saying something something
as fundamental as evil doesn't run
through all these cultures and all these
religious traditions then how can you
make the claim that everyone would agree
with your description of what
constitutes bad when we begin again
landscape it would be it's just it's
just not it's not evil in the sense that
that it's there's better and worse
there's better than words okay so can we
can we have there's either universal
moral intuitions or there are no is it
yes no but you are some moral intuitions
Universal yes no I would think that
listen we are just human beings right
we're human beings first before we're
Hindu or Buddhist or Christian we can
all get indoctrinated into the religion
of our parents this is a an artifice
that's laid on top of something far
deeper that should be obvious so right
so so I'm trying to get down to what's
deeper okay so there may be so there may
be some moral universals sure I think
okay Jordan no but possible that there
are some moral intuitions that are
highly specific to particular traditions
and wouldn't translate over to others
yes oh it's a highly probable because
there would be environment specific
adaptations like the environment
specific tool use of chimpanzees right
or maybe it's not even the environment
maybe
the self-consistency of the belief
pattern in question so I'm sure I would
put that in the broader environment it
might be a consequence of the particular
ease of that culture there would be
things that look think about it like
languages like many and that this is
kind of an answer to the problem that
you you laid out which is a real problem
I'm not trying to deny the problem if
you look at there's a lot of languages
lots of languages look at how different
they are it's like yeah at some levels
of analysis they're fundamentally
different and at other levels of
analysis they're fundamentally the same
which is how we know that they're
languages and you could say well there's
a very large number of stories it's like
yes there are but the fact that there's
enough commonality across the class of
stories the set of all possible stories
so that we can identify what constitutes
a story and I would say that there's
enough commonality across the set of all
possible good stories that we can say
well here's a canonical good story which
is by the way what you do at the
beginning of the moral landscape because
you say this is horrible this is good
we should move from what's horrible to
what's good say yes you're you've you've
taken a fragment of the universal story
and you've made it the axiom of your
moral system which is what you should do
it's but but the claim that that I think
is not helpful even though I understand
it is that that's purely a claim of like
of unmediated fact it's like no there is
no unpeople there is yes even facts
aren't unmediated facts I mean you can't
right hand you can't judge something to
be factual without presupposing the
validity of certain intuitions like
right that that causes precede events
you know so our causes precede their
effects and those intuitions could be
wrong I mean we could live in a
teleological universe where everything
is getting pulled into the future by
some kind of a tractor right and our
notion of causation is totally backwards
that remains to be discovered and we
have we would use other intuitions to
make that discovery so is it again you
do pull yourself up by your bootstraps
and that there's there's no branch of
science or mathematics or anything
fundamental logic that can get away from
that right right well that's another
place but given that
picture that doesn't render all
intuitions equally respectable
absolutely someone says well I happen to
have an intuition that that Joseph Smith
saw those golden tablets and they were
you know in Mormonism is true that's not
the sort of intuition we're talking
about here
your intuition doesn't look well rigged
insight into history we could say a
Brett's point is that like moral
intuitions of the sort that you're
describing have different zones of
relevance so there's some things that
would only work as an intuition in very
delimited areas of time and space let's
say there's a hierarchy of moral
intuitions and the more profound the
intuition the more it works as a
universal truth across contexts just
like in a scientific truth so the
scientific truth is more profound this
is why the postmodernist readings of
Thomas Kuhn are wrong is that the idea
that protons are real is really
fundamental because no matter what span
of time and space that you pick you're
going to encounter protons it works
everywhere and then with moral
intuitions let's say are morally
priorities you have the same issue as
some of them are so delimited that they
only work here and now and those are
sort of impulsive low-level intuitions a
whim even but some of them are really
really deep the ones for example the one
that Orient's you to make the claim that
you made in the moral landscape that the
hellish story is bad and the heavenly
story is good right I would say that's
one of the deepest most context
independent moral intuitions which which
is kind of the claim you make except you
claimed it and again back to my
fundamental concern here and in the
difference with respect to the
difference in with how we talk about
these things to call that thing God is
fine that's a god I have no problem with
right but that's not how most people
most of the time are using the word and
there's something misleading about that
and that's that worries me yeah well if
if the claim
if the claim that you're making is that
we're all deeply confused about the
nature of divinity and ultimate reality
it's like yeah yes another thing we
agree on I also don't disagree
I don't disagree look I've never said
I've never made the claim that what I'm
talking about is like what other people
are talking about I mean it is in some
ways but I've not made that claim so I
don't see why that's a justifiable
criticism it's like well no it's a it's
a criticism in the with respect to the
very likely effects of communicating in
that way because I see the results of
that communication it's a little bit I
mean this is gonna sound more invidious
than it is but they have the kind of
thing that I get into a Deepak Chopra
yeah Deepak and I agree about a lot I
think it's more invidious than it sounds
actually yeah well you're not wearing
rhinestone book glasses with you if you
graduate to that we'll have more of a
problem but it's Deepak clearly wants to
let his audience believe that everything
they're into is on some level
justifiable by his reading of quantum
spookiness right so it's all so you know
if you want to go out and just buy a lot
of crystals and think they're gonna heal
you it has something to do with really
nothing like you know know what I'm
saying but I think Deepak could say if I
if I got his back to the wall yeah
Deepak could say honestly say listen
I've never said anything about crystals
right I'm not selling crystals I've
never said they work but it's it's the
way in which he's failing to make the
clear differentiation defendant that the
fact that it takes you 20 minutes to
admit that there's that a lot of the
Bible is filled with barbaric nonsense
they're like it took me 20 minutes to
admit these things matter these things
matter and I'm just saying it's like you
say that you injure if you're in a
parish of 1 or in a parish of 1000 or a
parish of a hundred thousand but not in
the parish that has anything in common
with the with the bible thumpers in my
country who think that Jesus is very
likely coming back in their lifetime
because he never died and he's gonna
judge the living and the dead and there
will be a resurrection and Hellfire and
all the rest if that's not the game
you're playing at all on it why why are
you why are you why are you all
applauding about that it's like what
what do you mean own it it's like I
already made my claim it's like I'm not
playing a religious fundamentalist game
so what's all the applause about so I
don't understand that and own it it's
like I was just listen I was as clear as
I possibly could be when I delineate it
my answer to the question people say
well what do you mean by God asked you
if Jesus was one second answer but no
well forget it
Jordan Jordan Jordan women well I think
we can actually this is one second I
don't want to end on it I don't want to
end on a note of acrimony but someone
once asked you whether you thought Jesus
was literally resurrected and you said
it would take me 40 hours to answer that
question okay that's that's that's the
kind of thing I'm responding to here you
don't need to do that if you have a
clear-cut answer to that question I
don't have it clear down to a few bones
and if you don't that that connects with
many other things that we still have to
talk about
yes definitely yeah because because that
it isn't obvious in the biblical account
that Christ was literally resurrected so
it's not simple no no no no it don't but
if the question is do you think he won't
let us put it probabilistically I mean
anything's possible I'll tell you that
it's possible that he was physically
resurrected I mean it's it's not it's
even wait a second ID with respect to
quantum mechanics the point is yes it
would take me 40 hours to answer the
question I didn't say that he was we'll
go ahead way how's this for an answer
almost certainly not what's what's
what's wrong with that answer you want I
think I think I know what's wrong with
that answer it's it's a it's a fine
answer and people have been giving that
answer for a very long period of time
but the idea doesn't seem to go away
okay and there's evidence of what
exactly I don't know okay I can tell you
one thing it's an evidence of all right
a deep idea let this be the doorway to
our next three-hour conversation sure
they clearly weren't sure so we have we
have ten minutes left
okay well then let's answer that
question in ten minutes
so wait I want you to trust me here you
for whatever reason decided I should
moderate so I want you to trust me
one thing you finish the Omens worse I
really would like to answer that
question like but I'm trying to figure
out if people seem to think that I'm
trying to evade the question it's like
not evading the question I'm trying to
figure it out it's a really people have
been arguing about this for 2,000 years
it's like it's not simple that's a simp
that's a symptom of the effect of
religious dogma tis 'm for 2,000 years
no it's not okay it's hardly a symptom
of that it's also partly a symptom of
the idea the resurrection of Jesus is
clearly an important question but you've
raised a much bigger and more pressing
question for the audience which is
whether or not God cares whether they
masturbate so I actually think if we
pursue that answer that we will actually
wrap this up in a way that you want to
end this on masturbation
I think we owe it to them or - okay so
well hey give me a little leisure that
the floor is yours how did I end up here
alright so here's here's the question
let's just figure out if we can
determine why God might care if you
masturbate right so let's suppose that
we have a story a heuristic of some kind
that stands in for something and the
story is God is watching he sees you
always he doesn't want you masturbating
so don't you dare what happens what
happens yeah
well it's it's rather ineffectual news
idea yeah well I mean if you think that
story I think some people from well no
but I think the reality was was that you
had people masturbating and feeling
terrible about it and you had a whole
layer of sexual neurosis that we got
grafted on to human psychology
unnecessarily okay so she Anna T has a
certain technology of sexual hang-up
array which which you know that the
tantra --cz don't have so if i
understand you correctly you are
agreeing that a certain amount certain
number of people will get masturbate
some of some of them join the priesthood
and raped little boys I mean that song
is their topic so a certain number of
people will have masturbated they will
have thought honestly is the same topic
I mean that though that the taboos
around masturbation the taboos around
sexuality prior to marriage the taboo
around divorce
all of the taboo around out of wedlock
birth the the ideal of celibacy in the
priesthood all of that is a is it just a
diabolical machine of needless sexual
conflict and misery will hold on hold on
and but yes okay you have to take how's
the whole flood of pornography thing
working out okay great
I will I will grant you that there is
some interpretation that takes
supernatural principles and magic and
other worldliness out of the equation
here that gets you some wisdom in the
heuristic yes if you're masturbating all
the time you're not satisfying you are
you're monogamous relationship with your
wife or husband we don't need to go
there let's just
you're not procreating and we just agree
that a certain amount of masturbation
was presented was prevented by that
story which made people fear the
consequence of them engaging in it which
would result in I'm pretty sure less
yes masturbation which means that in
seeking a release which we are
physiologically programmed to seek one
might end up looking in a more urgent
fashion for a mate right so so it's are
we going to enforce monogamy as a No so
look I'm trying to take you somewhere I
think I think there is a way that we can
rescue some important part of what both
of you are saying that can now be
reconciled and then there's a bitter
pill for each of you I mean that's just
the way this looks to me so if we can
agree that this makes sense actually is
a Fitness enhancing adaptation that this
story would result in people behaving in
a way that might result in the marrying
early might result in them reproducing
earlier than they would otherwise right
then we can understand it as mechanistic
and we can understand what you said that
you know maybe God would care about
whether or not people masturbate because
God is a metaphor for some set of
stories that gets you to behave in an
adaptive fashion but the point for you
then would be that Sam is arguing with
reason we can decide whether or not to
employ this story at this moment whether
it's a good idea for us to urgently
reproduce as quickly as possible which
for example increases the size of the
population of the planet whereas
delaying reproduction keeps the rate of
population growth down and might be a
better choice for a moment in his
we have seven and a half billion people
on the planet so in some sense what I
think I see is the religious story
itself make some kind of sense if you
adhere to it in a manner that you are
obligated and I have no tools with which
to question it
then you will miss the fact that at this
moment you might want to throw that
story but the problem is it doesn't
makes and this is this is a problem with
these heuristics in general it doesn't
make sense for the right reason and
that's why it's not a reliable guide
given other changes in the world but
with everything changing you want to be
making sense for the right reason you
don't want it like this a useful
fictions have to be retired at a certain
point useful truths stay true I mean if
you because they're based on your
engagement with reality and so to take
your point about pornography which i
think is totally valid
you could have a completely rational
conversation in terms of human
psychology and sociology and what you
want society to look like about the
corrosive nature of pornography right
that's not you don't have to be a
Victorian prude to worry that there
might be something wrong with the
infinite availability of pornography to
thirteen-year-olds and above right I
mean this that's I don't know what
what's generation of human beings were
raising in the current environment it's
it's you know it's quite worrisome
actually but again you don't have to
invoke mythology to do that and I would
say the temptation to invoke mythology
said well you actually you know how do
you do it beside and really gets pissed
off when you master how do you how do
you do it how do you do it we don't have
many effects you have no mechanism for
control about the effects on human
relationships and your own mind and your
own intention and the way you view other
pieces have enough fairly words for sex
ed it barely works for condom education
well what was already works like those
sorts of educational interventions to
stop that kind of fundamental behavior
have very little effect well people
aren't nearly as amenable to behavioral
changes as a consequence of rational
educational interventions as you might
hope I mean in that that's that's part
and parcel of but that broad clinical
literature
there they're not as Ament they're not
as amenable to dogmatic intrusions
either I mean that they are well that
might be a problem there are problems
well no because because there again this
is just this is all this is all you know
the problem is that this even if you
could make the case that a dogmatic
attachment to one or another religion
was better all things considered than
being secular it's truly secular and
truly rational right
it's vulnerable it's it's vulnerable to
every next thing we find out I mean
that's why it's like you could have said
to go back you know 200 years before the
germ theory of disease you could have
said well all of these dietary taboos
and and taboos around you know
hand-washing and put washing it's
actually very wise the wisdom of the
germ theory of disease was sort of built
into our Scripture and people were
survived there was a kind of
differential level of survival based on
those who really adhere to these these
practices and those who didn't okay but
it one it's blind to the actual
variables like is there's nothing
special about shellfish necessarily or
there's nothing special about pork
necessarily or whatever the example is
and once you get the actual variables in
hand then the whole edifice comes
crashing down and then you really just
want to understand the variables that
work look I don't know if I don't know
if the whole edifice comes crashing down
and it isn't clear to me that you want
to claim that because one of the things
you did say in the moral landscape and I
think this is associated with your
interest in spirituality is that there
is some baby mixed in with the bathwater
and the question is how do we how do we
how do we distill that out yeah and the
objections that you're raising are the
objections that are look how difficult
it is to do the distillation it's like
yeah absolutely man and it's not like
I'm a foal of the Enlightenment I think
you enlightenment types and I put Pinker
in the same cab a radically overestimate
the degree to that was that was a cause
of sui it's like everyone was barbaric
and superstitious until 1750 and some
miracle occurred and now we're all in
what we all became enlightened like
there was a lengthy develop
clearly all haven't them in with this
hence hence two are complaining about
the problem and most of the world most
of the world hasn't had the
Enlightenment drew on some look no no
fold the Enlightenment but I think that
it had a lengthy developmental history
that is Braddock Lee under played by the
people who who grounded purely in
rationality it's clearly still
developing my point is we we should be
able to agree that having a worldview
guided by a continuous honest engagement
with reality and so far as we can
apprehend it is better than having a
worldview solidified or anchored to
unchanging ideas that were born of
people who had none of our present tools
none of our present insights into
anything Paul it depends on it depends
on the principles it depends on the
principles like I would say there there
are situations where that clearly
applies but I think there are broad
principles and again we should probably
stop with this I think yep I'm out there
because I'm I'm starting to get tired
I'm sure everyone else in here is
starting to get tired well I'm starting
to get tired anyways and I mean the the
there are there are principles there are
higher order principles of the sort that
I described that you also appear to rely
on in the moral landscape the idea of
these profound moral intuitions yeah and
so that's what I'm after is what are
these profound moral intuitions and what
is their source and like I'm also
perfectly willing to make the claim and
have in fact in in detail that these
moral intuitions see that this is a
place where we differ a little bit it's
like and maybe we can go here tomorrow
night see it seems to me that that you
for you for you in your argument is the
facts are laying out there and you can
extract out value from them and and we
already described why you want to do
that because you want to at least not
move into the nihilistic direction and
you want to ground them in some sort of
reality it's like fair enough but the
thing is is that the facts as they are
have been around for a very very very
very long time
right let's say three and a half billion
years the entire expanse of life and
it's the operation of those facts on
life that has produced the a priori
implicit interpretive structures that
guide our interaction with the facts and
those a priori implicit structures that
have emerged out of this evolutionary
course have a structure that mediates
between us and the facts that cannot be
derived from the facts at hand so so
then the question is what is that
structure and and it's in both of our
interests to get that right yeah because
you use that as the source of moral
intuition it's like right agreed that's
the source of moral intuition so and and
Clint clearly what we need to table this
for tomorrow night but that's a good
yeah guys I'm just going to interrupt
you guys let's give Jordan Peterson Sam
Harrison Pat one side a huge ham let's
go
thank you